joining me this week is your own Brook
president of the Iran Institute and
co-author of the book equal is unfair
your own welcome to the show thanks for
having me on I am very excited to talk
to you because you guys sent me
literature usually usually people send
me a book maybe I got the book too but I
got literature that's not a tremendous
amount of reading oh good that's couple
of days so I'm looking forward to this
so Iran I mentioned at the top of the
show if just by saying her name just by
saying Iran a certain percentage of
people go bonkers go completely bonkers
I mean I'm sure I'm not in lumen aiding
you in any way now so so before we get
into the specifics of Objectivism and
her philosophy what tell me a little bit
just about her as the president sure I
mean I know and was born to a
middle-class Jewish family in in st.
Petersburg Russia
she was Alicia Rosenbloom right that
wasn't named and she witnessed communism
she saw it happen she lived under it in
her teenage years and it was clear given
her personality that she was not going
to survive she was not going to live
through communism she was going to get
in trouble so the family got together
and they and they got her out and
basically there was a window of
opportunity with Lenin allowed some
people out to do research or do
something with their studies she got out
in the early 20s came to the United
States with nothing spent some time with
family Chicago but then showed up in
Hollywood her dream was to be a
scriptwriter to be a writer and she
loved Hollywood movie she left silent
movies and she goes to the first day she
goes to the Cecil B DeMille studios and
you know it's a letter of introduction
and they say don't call us we'll call
you
she walks out and there's this big
convertible and Cecil B DeMille is
sitting right there and he drives by and
she's staring and she's this little
Russian woman she's staring at me with
these big eyes and he stops the car and
he says why are you staring and she
tells him the story I'm here from Russia
I love your movies he says get in Wow
and he takes at the back lot where
they're filming the King of Kings story
of Jesus Christ and he says here's a
weeklong pass so that you can see how
movies are made you want to be in the
movie business this is how movies are
made so she does that she'll ends up
being an extra in the movie she
meeting a future husband on the set and
this is an entry point into Hollywood
and and she gets many many little jobs
in Hollywood as at night she is writing
and practicing her English and she works
in the wardrobe department she works as
extras she works in akka but in the end
she becomes a scriptwriter and she
writes up script some of the some of the
movies are made and in addition she
writes a couple of plays they are put on
in both LA and Ana Broadway she writes a
book called we the living which is the
most autobiographical thing she ever
wrote which is about a young woman
growing up under communism in the Soviet
Union and the choices she has to make
and so what were what were some of those
things before we well you have over some
of the failures that she had to deal
with or what were some of the things
that she had to live under with coming
in communism well you know you couldn't
express your own opinion you had a play
out the party line her father who owned
a pharmacy a private pharmacy it was
nationalized it was taken away from him
they went from living a middle-class
life in a nice kind of apartment to
sharing an apartment with other families
they during the civil war in Russia they
escaped to the to the to the Black Sea
and then had to go back to some
Petersburg and just the greyness the
conformity that everybody being the same
the the the lack of any opportunities
there like of any future what are you
gonna do you're always going to be the
same yeah there's no progress there's no
there's no success they no advancement
you are expected to conform to stand and
this is what we the living is about it's
a brilliant book it's a short book and
it was made into a movie by in Italy in
1942 I think and lated we discovered in
the 1960s the book failed and the book
failed because you yoke Intelligencia in
the 1930s were kind of enamored with
communism right Tommy nism was kind of
cool right and he was a book saying no
communism was evil
and it was really one of the first books
to paint that picture of communism this
is what's actually going on in Russia
not what you reading in the New York
Times which is propaganda but this is
what's actually going on she then wrote
a little book called anthem which she
couldn't find a publisher for in the
United States
and land up being published in the UK a
year or two before 1984 so it's kind of
a dystopian novel and there's there's
evidence that all well probably read it
and then she wrote a book called The
Fountainhead and The Fountainhead was
rejected by 12 publishers ultimately
published became a word-of-mouth
bestseller to this day sells over a
hundred thousand copies a year is is a
best-seller has shaped in influenced the
lives of many many people it's about an
architect yeah and I don't know any
architect out there yeah I don't know
any architect out there hasn't read the
found head it hasn't been impacted by
The Fountainhead it took a 12 years to
identic spoke Ellis shrugged and that
book became an instant bestseller
you know publishers competed for it and
then she spent the rest of her life that
was published in 1957 she spent the rest
of her life she died in 82
writing nonfiction developing the
philosophy that she had discovered for
Atlas Shrugged that you really developed
in Atlas Shrugged we're really
articulating its applications in all
kinds of areas so she rose newsletters
and articles and books of essays from
19th through the 60s and into the 70s
and and again she died in 1982 working
you know while she was still was still
writing and very active yeah so I wanted
to get a little bit of her history out
because I feel like people don't know
some of the history that this is someone
who came from communism who came to love
America and capitalism and sort of
living for yourself which is a lot of
what objectivism is so now let's unpack
objective is show a little bit there
sort of there are five pillars and give
me the the broadest objective this shows
so so objectivism in one foot kind of is
in metaphysics which is which is the the
aryan philosophy that that studies what
is out there what is reality about you
know it's reality is what it is a is a
kind of law of identity the law of
causality Aristotle's view of the
metaphysical nature of reality reality
is not created by another being it's not
what we want it to be it's not what we
wish it to be it's not what some
external consciousness created it just
is it's here and now it's here and now
it's in we and we have and this is kind
of the epistemology we have the tool to
know it we have senses to observe it and
we have reason to be able to integrate
it understand it and actually ultimately
shape it it's not a creation of our
consciousness it's not a creation of our
motions the way the way you learn about
reality is not two emotions it's through
reason it's through science it's through
using you know what's unique the human
which is a reasoning capacity a rational
thinking our senses and our senses are
valid now thinking being we having
reason being rational is a
characteristic of the individual we
don't have a collecting stomach to eat
we don't have a collective mind to think
only individuals can't think so the unit
in ethics is the individual that the
purpose of ethics is to provide guidance
for the individual on how to live the
best life that he can live what values
and virtues to pursue to live a great
life right and to live a life consistent
with our nature as human beings as
rational reasoning beings so ethics is
not about teaching us how to sacrifice
for other people how to die for them but
it's also not about getting other people
to sacrifice for us and in exploiting
other people it's about living a full
rational life right so okay so let's
spend three that's three right so let's
pause there for a second so a lot of
what I've talked about here is that one
of my problems with what has become the
modern left is that they seem to now
care more about the collective than the
individual and ayaan Hirsi Ali who I've
had on you know she always talks about
if you care about minorities you have to
care about minorities within minorities
that's very much an Objectivist way of
looking at things
well I'm man said the smallest minority
in the world is the individual that's
what it's all about so the framework for
everything in politics in morality is
the individual not the group but you see
them all left has bigger problems in my
view yeah that is the modern left has
rejected the idea of reason the idea of
reason is actually being efficacious in
the world it's ejected reason
as the standard you know beyond science
and even in science there's some
questions but beyond science they
rejected reason as the standard by which
we should evaluate reality this comes
from philosophers like Kant and Hegel
and Schopenhauer and so on the German
Continental tradition which basically
said reason is a mind game it's in here
we don't know what reality is you know
we can speculate about what we real
reality is but what we see is ultimately
shaped by consciousness not by reality
our senses actually distort reality they
don't identify reality that has created
a real epistemological and ultimately
modeling political problems throughout
the last hundred fifty years so this is
where you would say that we care sort of
more about feelings over fact sometimes
things will feel right to us it seems
right to say well the minimum wage
should be $15 because you want people
that are low income to make more money
that feels right but it may not actually
be the what the system itself can nagoya
it's not what happens in reality that is
and this is what people call unintended
consequences I'm not sure they're always
unintended but the unintended
consequences is if you think a little
bit more about the problem and in let's
take the minimum wage yeah if you raise
the price artificially we all study in
econ 101 when a price is raised demand
goes down so if you raise the price of
labor then demand for that labor goes
down and this happens over and over
again and and and but people don't want
they don't think they leave that but
they also don't want to take the
inductive evidence that is the fact that
it's happened a hundred times oh but
this time it's going to be different and
I see that in economics all the time the
Paul Krugman's of the world stimulus
never works it's never worked that's
because it hasn't been big enough we
need do bigger and it's never going to
work because they they keep loading it
up like that and the same with a minimum
wage they keep thinking this time will
be different but that's anti reason it's
anti science and what they're placing is
wishes before fact wishes before solid
theoretical theory theory there was
derived from evidence from reality I
mean that's a real scientific method
right so when I've watched these debates
let's just stick on them in
wage now for a moment now and you know
Bernie says the $15 minimum wage and I
said it it feels good and I've worked
minimum-wage jobs too when I was in high
school I think I was making $6 maybe an
hour it might have even been less I'm
not even sure but it sounds good but
what they also because they don't think
through well McDonald's if they're
forced to go from 750 an employee or
whatever it is $9 an employee to 15
they're just going to replace them all
with iPads right I mean that's what I
mentioned at the top of the show so
absolutely so first of all you get iPads
to take orders iPads are much more
efficient at taking orders to people
yeah and but but they're actually
machines now they will flip the burgers
they will do the whole process and bring
you out wrapped nicely iboga whatever
you ordered on the iPad will get so
automation automation is going to happen
anyway right but this speeds it up and
people are less prepared for it but more
than that it's going to mean the
teenagers if you're a teenager growing
up in the inner cities and you're not
trained because public education is a
disaster yeah well see you have no
skills right so now you expect it to be
able to perform at fifteen bucks an hour
you can't the fact is nobody will pay
somebody to produce ten dollars it won't
pay the 15 to produce ten right I'm not
going to lose when I I tell this to kids
right when somebody hires you they're
going to make money off of you that's
the nature of the transaction you're
going to make money off of them because
your time is actually worth less than
what you're willing to take it to salary
but they're going to make money off of
you nobody's going to hire a kid who
can't produce more than seven bucks an
hour at fifteen bucks an hour so those
kids are just going to be priced out so
whether it means the McDonald shuts down
whether it means they automate whether
it means they raised a jack up prices
significantly so the people now can't
afford to buy the food that they're
producing so that nothing's changed in
that sense it's not good policy we can
talk about how to help poor people
particularly inner-city kids yeah but
minimum wage is the dumbest stupidest
most economically ignorant idea of an
even Jerry Brown gets it right because
why was this negotiated here in
California they negotiated like a
six-year term to phase in it right it's
because there was a ballot initiative
there was going to go into effect that
would have
had minimum wage go up in the next three
years and Jerry Brown looked at that
oh my god this is going to be disastrous
for the California economy so I'll
compromise with these guys by spreading
it out which is the least damaging thing
he could have done but even Jerry Brown
said their trade-offs and what are the
trade-offs unemployment among young
people take some entrepreneurs going out
of business and yes some people will
make a little bit more money those are
the kind of trade-offs that I find ugly
right and this is where critical
thinking is so important because when
I've watched the debates Bernie says the
fifteen and gets applause for it because
it sounds good feels good Hillary said
something like well we're gonna get it
to twelve and then figure it out now I'm
not even defending her other than to say
that at least she's trying to play the
game at least of reality right so in a
weird way you have to credit her she's
doing the Jerry Brown thing yes but this
is this is a sad thing about American
America right now and this this is on
the right and the left because we're
seeing the same thing with Donald Trump
is that after what I believe is about a
century of progressive education where
we've taught kids not to think but to
feel not to be reasoning rational agents
but to be feeling agents we are
suffering the consequences now so we've
got politicians who appeal purely to
emotion that don't discuss facts that
don't discuss evidence don't discuss
Trump and Boni drop bad Boni right and
don't discuss how they're gonna get
there they don't discuss the details
they don't discuss how they pay for it
we're gonna give you free stuff we're
gonna we're gonna you know we're gonna
get back it to Chinese as if the Chinese
are the problem and so on and so forth
right but it's all emotion it's all
about emotion any of people are
responding and of course you know you've
talked about free speech but this is the
same kind of thing we're seeing on
American campuses today you can't say
something that might offend somebody or
and what does it mean to offend it means
that it's a little bit out of the
mainstream because their emotions the
hood and we're saying emotions are what
matter will give you a safe space will
give you will give you triggers will
protect your emotions no we should be
protecting the mind and the way to
protect the mind is to expand it is they
expose them to lots of different ideas
and teach them to critical thinking
skills then it is necessary to figure
out what's right what's wrong what makes
sense what does
make sense but that's out and I'm this
is what scares me the most about America
today
it's just emotionalism so in that sense
it's an epistemological point it's not
even ethics it's not politics this is
about what is the tool for knowing
reality is it emotion what is it the
mind yeah well you're throwing me all of
my favorite stuff right there between
the free speed yet open and weary
completely on free speech yeah so wait
so circling back to objectivism did we
did we miss any piece of it sure we
missed a politics show yeah we so if
individuals are the model unit if the
purpose of morality is to guide us
towards our own individual happiness if
the purpose of morality is to give us
the values and virtues and if it turns
out as objectivism holds that the most
important of those is reason so our
cardinal value if you will is is to
cultivate your reason your vote the the
most important virtue the virtue that
integrates all other virtues is
rationality then the question is okay
what kind of a world does a reasoning
rational individual list demand in order
to be able to exercise his reason and
rationale and the answers freedom all he
wants us to be free to be left alone so
he can exercise his mind and pursue the
values that he believes a good frame now
if I turned out that he's wrong but then
he needs to learn and adjust and he
needs to make those decisions and he
should be allowed to make mistakes and
the enemy of Reason is force the enemy
of reason is coercion so what we want is
a political system that protects us from
coercion and and the concept of
individual rights which the
Enlightenment came up with Locke and
then the founding fathers is the concept
that recognizes that fact it recognizes
the idea that in order for people to
exercise their reason they have to be
free and individual rights me and this
is the right to life means the pursuit
of values necessary Yola the right to
Liberty means think what you want to
think say what you want to say write
what you want to write you have a right
to use your mind in any way that you can
in pursuit of happiness right that's the
ultimate goal so they recognize this
individualism so the core there is
is freedom and they and and and the way
I see freedom the only free political
system is a capitalist political system
a system in which the government's only
job is to protect us from coercion it's
only job is to protect us from the use
of force so that's for the fifth pillar
which is a whole other area in
philosophy which I don't know if we talk
about is aesthetics that is given the
type of consciousness that we have we
need a particular kind of art to reflect
back to us the values that we have so
that it can inspire us so that it can it
can keep us going it provides us with
important cognitive and emotional fuel
so Iran believed in Romanticism as that
that favre art a representational had to
represent something but then it has to
inspire and and she defined romanticism
is art that recognizes the fact that
individuals have free will right and and
all ought to recognize that she would
consider a superior art form to other
art forms that's that's what she didn't
have to she didn't have to like the art
specifically right if the number if the
artist themselves was expressing all of
their humanity right well they exactly
the best example of that is the she'd
love she she recognized the genius and
the greatness of Dostoevsky and he
considered him a Romantic artist because
he recognized free well if you've read
dusky you know I mean his characters are
torn between choices right and she loved
that kind of out that was essence about
but philosophically she was opposed to
everything dust EF ski boat right she
viewed his view of life as bleak as as
as awful who go is another one who go
who was a socialist and lemmy's oorah
blurs ultimately has kind of a socialist
the plight of the poor type of theme she
considered who go the greatest literary
figure in human history the greatest
writer in human history and and a great
romantic writer because he had all these
conflicts in this drama which she loved
right so that's really fascinating so
she didn't like the ideas that these
people were putting forth but she loved
them as individuals right she loved the
idea she loved a were expressing she
loved the aesthetic she loved the way
they communicated the idea
and the recognition so what she
separated is so there's certain
political ideas up here but she believed
that much more important that the
political ideas are the fundamental
philosophical ideas so she looks at who
going he says here's a here's a great
author who recognizes something very
very important maybe the most important
thing about human beings we have free
will versus many modern artists many
modern authors where the story just
rambles along nobody makes any choices
everything's by accident she would say
that the nine free will so even if they
use beautiful prose Shakespeare is a
good example of this right even if they
use beautiful prose and they buy
beautiful stuff because they deny free
will you know I really really hate that
now I admire the prose I'd my the story
I'd might but I but I resent them
philosophically who go because he
recognizes something more fundamental
than politics in a sense I'm willing to
forgive the bad politics because we're
allies under more fundamental philosophy
I can get a lot of fuel spiritual fuel
from the recognition of heroes even if
they're fighting for something I don't
believe in right so really more than
anything else it sounds to me like she
wanted to have the battle of ideas and
that's very much what I do here what I
try to get people to think about and to
talk about but unfortunately don't seem
to live in a time when this is working
right as you just said between the the
Trump stuff giving you easy answers and
the Bernie stuff giving you easy answers
we don't live in a time when the
underlying bedrock is cared about but
this is the danger of living in a time
where we've elevated emotions among all
else because once you accept emotions as
your standard it's nothing you talk
about right because because it's a
question of below what what you're
saying makes me feel XO what you're
saying makes you feel but that's not a
conversation a conversation is about
reason it's about ideas it's about proof
it's about evidence and that is that
requires critical thinking skills and we
we have trained maybe several
generations with socially the latest
generation not to think to mo when we
when we have five year olds or seven
year olds and nine year old sitting
around a classroom and we ask them what
do you think about something political
well that's ridiculous a five year old
doesn't think about politics again
even a nine-year-old can think what what
nine-year-olds need is is a lot of
knowledge a lot of information in the
skills the math and science skills that
train you in how to think and our public
education system has destroyed that so
what she was interested in is reason
above all she said I'm a champion of
capitalism because I'm a champion of
rational self-interest as my Mago but
I'm a champion of rational self-interest
as my Mago because I'm a champion of
reason as man's basic means of survival
is to love knowledge
so the fundamental fine Rand's
philosophy and this is what I think so
many people don't get and and they they
respond emotionally to it is reason you
know and a lot of your audience says
with a science will for reason we're for
facts were for sign well this is a man
now now we can debate the politics but
let's at least agree that the standard
by which we have this debate is a
standard of rationality it's a standard
of facts and evidence